et bonjour stéphane le foll merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin vous
êtes le maire socialiste dumont et notre
ensemble pendant 20 minutes on est servi
en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
cressat bertrand du groupe la dépêche
bonjour christelle adriano journée à
laquelle on va parler de la crise
sanitaire pour commencer stéphane le
foll puisque le sénat examine en ce
moment le texte qui transforme le passé
annie terre on passe vaccinale est ce
que vous êtes favorable elle se passe
vaccinale est ce que vous le voteriez si
vous êtes les parlementaires oui je
foutrais se passe ce vaccinale je pense
que l'enjeu n'est pas une protection
individuelle comme c'est souvent rappelé
ou 10 ou libertés individuelles c'est
une démarche collective pour essayer de
s'en sortir de manière collective on a
un virus qui circule de manière
extrêmement rapide maintenant
et on le sait le vaccin les trois doses
protège pas de la circulation ni de la
transmission potentielle du virus mais
protège des cas les plus graves et ceux
qui conduisent des hôpitaux les
réanimations à être souvent dans des
situations extrêmement délicate et
difficile donc c'est ça l'enjeu c'est un
jeu collectif
après il faut être capable de discuter
de convaincre d'essayer de faire
comprendre que la rn messager cette
nouvelle manière qui a été découverte
avec eux le vivent pas avec les russes
d'ailleurs avant mais qui a été utilisée
qui je le crois aussi aujourd'hui tu en
train d'être utile potentiellement pour
un vaccin contre le sida on sait une
rupture scientifique majeure je
comprends que des gens qui se disent
qu'est ce qu'ils sont en train de faire
mais au-delà de tout ça pue recul qu'il
nôtre aujourd'hui et les bénéfices de la
vaccination par rapport aux risques
décès je veux dire il faut continuer à
convaincre j'aurais voté le pass
vaccinale dans cet état d'esprit sans
stigmatiser personne pour revenir à des
formules que le président de la
république a utilisé sa future wii on
veut pas faire ça sur le fond sur la
forme
sur le fond je pense que depuis le début
on n'a pas assez mis l'accent sur ce
coup disais tout à l'heure c'est pas une
démarche individuelle c'est pas une
liberté qu'on les seconds le spa c'est
une manière collective de sortir d'une
situation sanitaire difficile cette nuit
les sénateurs ont repoussé la
possibilité de contrôler les identités
des gens qui pourraient aller au
restaurant ou dans les bars est ce que
vous comprenez cette ville comprend en
même temps j'ai vu et vous l'avez tous
remarqué que dans les bars et dans les
restaurants le départ houleux pas
sanitaire qui était une demande de
contrôle de la part des restaurateurs ou
de tous ceux qui tiennent des batteurs
jeté pour un café dans un des cafés qui
a autour du sénat très sympa vous
demande de passer y faire maintenant
c'est devenu une démarche totalement
acceptée facile et tout ça ah bon alors
après la pièce d'identité à notre sujet
donc le pass vaccinale bien il y avait
un pass sanitaires il doit être demandée
vérifier avec ces trois vaccins ça me
semble être une démarche qui doit
continuer comme ça rajoutez la question
d'identité parce qu'il ya des faux c'est
ça oui mr la question des faux si j'ai
bien compris c'est que certains dans le
monde médical accepte de faire défaut
donc ce qu'il faut c'est d'abord traquer
tous ceux qui peuvent tricher
de faire défaut passe parce que ça c'est
un vrai sujet alors est-ce que si on va
demander la carte d'identité maintenant
pour rentrer dans un bar dans un
restaurant il ya tous ceux qui échangent
des parce qu'ils partagent impasse oui
il ya tous ceux qui échangent qui
partagent un passe normalement le passe
avec un co un qr code est quand même
suffisamment
repérable sont obligés d'y ajouter pour
les restaurateurs et les bars et les
restaurants la carte d'identité mais bon
on le sait n'a pas validé cette démarche
là assez sain les socialistes ont remis
hier à nouveau sur la table le débat sur
la vaccination obligatoire est ce que
vous
le brain de la vaccination obligatoire
là dessus julie judd il ya très
longtemps on dit on rend la vaccination
obligatoire donc ça a une conséquence
ceux qui ne se vaccinent pas on doit
dire qu'est ce qui se passe
dit la vaccination est obligatoire même
pour les enfants sur les vaccins qu'on
connaît pourquoi elle est obligatoire
parce que sinon vous pouvez pas aller à
l'école ou dans les crèches tiens il ya
une obligation qui est lié à un service
qui est ou pas rendu c'était ça la
vaccination obligatoire donc si on
rentre dans un débat sont obligatoires
pas obligatoire
la seule question qu'on doit poser à
ceux qui défendent 7e lille a les
socialistes en particulier oui mais
alors quelle est la sanction et qu'est
ce qui se passe si on n'est pas vacciné
donc là dessus vous êtes plus d'accord
avec la majorité présidentielle
dit on n'est pas fermés sur le principal
avec ces nations du gâteau et un
problème de faisabilité comment
contrôler je pense que ce problème est
réel et la question que vous vous posez
sur le pacs phase finale le pire étant
que des socialistes sont pour la
vaccination obligatoire et votre
contrôle passe axial s'il y en a
quelques uns je les ai vus à l'assemblée
voilà on vraiment on marche sur la tête
hein vraiment donc j'ai pas de leçon à
donner mais un tout petit peu de
cohérence ne fait de mal à personne
surtout en ce moment de la cohérence ça
aide à trouver les bonnes solutions
puisqu'on parle de cohérence demain les
enseignants seront nombreux à être en
grève
pour dénoncer la complexité du protocole
mis en place est ce que vous comprenez
ça oui je comprends que je pense que là
il ya eu
quand on dirige une mauvaise
appréciation un des conditions dans
lesquelles la rentrée l'espace est alors
mauvaise appréciation des mesures qui
étaient prises par rapport à la vitesse
de circulation du virus j'entends et je
sais que c'est pas toujours facile de
l'évaluer m'enfin on savait que cette
vitesse était extrêmement forte les
conditions et les contraintes qui ont
été mises par rapport à une circulation
rapide du virus était totalement
impossible à assumer et à gérer de
manière facile pour les écoles dans les
écoles pour les enseignants et puis
surtout pour les parents parce que la
multiplicité multiplicité des tests à
faire les risques à chaque fois de cas
contactez la fermeture des classes ou
trois claques contact tout ça me
semble-t-il n'a pas été mesuré à l'aune
de ce qui circule aujourd'hui c'est le
virus et a conduit un espèce de
d'impossibilité vous avez vu les files
d'attenté devant tous les sens tout est
donc là il ya eu une mauvaise évaluation
de la part du ministère et du ministère
a géré pour les élus pour le maire quand
vous êtes chez coca la mer avec ses
services sont j'allais dire en
accompagnement des enseignants dans les
écoles nos atsem tous les services qui
sont afférents et donc effectivement
avec les fermetures de classes on est
obligé d'avoir aussi des plannings tous
ses plannings sont remis en cause les
cantines on sait pas du jour au
lendemain ce qui doit être préparée
comme repas donc on a bien entendu des
difficultés ajustées ce qu'on produit
par rapport à ce qui va être consommée
non c'est très difficile et je comprends
la colère qui s'est exprimée depuis le
début de la rentrée est-ce que vous
pointez du doigt la responsabilité de
jean michel blanquer sûr que je pense je
voulais dits de mauvaise évaluation et
une mauvaise appréciation du des mesures
qui ont été annoncées par rapport à la
vitesse de circulation du virus il
aurait fallu reporter la rentrée au pas
forcément reporter la rentrée mais
repartir comme ça avait été fait
plusieurs fois avec peut-être des deux
me classe ou en tout cas sans le
la règle absolue du nom brassage qui
fait des quinquas contact enfin dès
qu'il y avait des cas qu'ovide dans une
classe ont fermé la classe là on a
totalement désorganisé
l'ensemble du dispositif de la rentrée
hier jean castex a reçu à matignon les
représentants des candidats à la
présidentielle et des parties pour
tenter d'organiser l'élection
présidentielle sous qu'ovide il a
beaucoup été question de vote par
correspondance est ce que vous y êtes
favorable et comment faire que
l'abstention ne soit pas moi je pense
que toute façon je dans le domaine du
vote il va falloir évoluer
sur les systèmes de vote et donc il faut
regarder alors par correspondance
même si c'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui à
mon avis un de la question de la
campagne présidentielle et de la
capacité que les gens vont avoir à se
déplacer ou pas
je crois que cette campagne elle est
très bizarre aujourd'hui
parce qu'il ya le poids de dans des mini
et vous avez une campagne je suis un élu
local fin j'étais ministre j'ai été
aussi directeur de campagne je suis
frappé de voir qu'aujourd'hui par
exemple dans une ville comme le mans est
partout d'ailleurs je regarde vous voyez
pas des affiches partout des gens qui
tracts sur les marchés comment vous
l'expliquez
ya autre chose il ya quelque chose de
2,2 d'un certain dans cette campagne qui
commet qui est dû aux candidats qui est
dû j'allais le dire aux candidats ou
thème
sûrement à la question sanitaire mais
aussi un espèce de nos campagnes alors
ça se passe au travers des médias avec
des phrases et des et souvent avec un
niveau qui n'est pas très élevé
d'ailleurs on n'est pas dans ce que vous
appelez un niveau pas très élevé au
football depuis les débats sur la
gastronomie des débats sur en mer d il
ya des débats sur kärcher à la hauteur
des enjeux à carter qui aurait dû rester
dans la cave enfin je veux dire tout ça
tout ça ça ne donne pas envie je le
crois profondément
quand on discute de la présidentielle
quand on est soi-même candidats ou
candidates on doit avoir une vision une
approche de la france dans l'europe dans
le monde et il se passe des choses
d'ailleurs dans le monde aujourd'hui
mais qu'aucun candidat n'a pour vous
pour l'instant enfin je vous dis la
campagne de manière générale
c'est un conseil je fais parce que mon
expérience comme je commence à en avoir
un peu d'expérience je vois que j'ai su
surpris de voir si peu de monde si peu
d'activité même pour des grands partis
je veux dans la sarthe quand même
département d'un ancien candidat à la
présidentielle et pas des moindres
françois fillon ça vient aujourd'hui ils
auraient pu me casser par hambourg mur
sur un marché
les affiches non plus c'est bizarre j'en
conviens de récoles ont passé vous ne
l'avez pas soutenu mais vous diriez
aujourd'hui daniel go qu'il n'y a pas de
vision dans son foyer le dit à juste que
je dis c'est que globalement il n'ya pas
oui j'ai passé à vouziers les candidats
est ce que vous incluez
ceinture jaune ici si je vous dis que
cette campagne elle est quand même assez
exceptionnel à la manière dont celle ci
est elle se déroule d'abord parce que
aller et ce avant chaotique elle est
pour la gauche dans une ase définition
une perte totale de boussole qui est
frappante je veux dire que quand on a un
total de gauche total qui est largement
à moins de 30% explique est deux fois et
demie dans un sondage publié hier par
l'ifop c'est moins que le salle emmanuel
macron qui fait 27 oui jamais vu de
simulations 65 ans aussi je reprends à
l'élection de 2012 combien faisait
françois hollande le relais tour 28 et
demi et il y avait autant de candidats
pratiquement saulcy taubira vient
s'ajouter
sera plutôt 2002 mais il y avait autant
de candidats 28 qu'est ce qui change
qu'est ce qui change ce qu'est ce qu'il
est pour vous d'abord parce qu'il ya eu
un effondrement du parti socialiste
parti gouvernement et partis majeurs de
la gauche quand vous avez une partie
majeure de la gauche est parti de
gouvernement c'est à dire parti capable
de porter une alternative à un
gouvernement quand c'était la droite
c'était pour la gauche est capable
d'incarner une alternance c'est à dire
d'avoir des personnalités qui pouvaient
être vues et reconnues comme étant en
capacité de diriger la france c'est ça
la question quand vous avez perdu ces
deux éléments là
vous avez une partie de cet électorat
visiblement il est resté chez emmanuel
macron et comme il n'y a plus d'
accroche dans les couches que j'appelle
un sécurisé populaires et moyennes vous
avez un parti qui n'a plus son centre
gauche et qui n'a plus la croche dans
les couches populaires regarder les
résultats que fait le parti socialiste
anne hidalgo anne hidalgo candidate du
parti socialiste à dire que tout ça ça
va ensemble on est à 3 4% donc ça veut
dire qu'on a perdu en
capacité de diriger la france sont
aujourd'hui mais b c'est pas simplement
à nivelles go si je vous dis oui mais je
parle de 23% de la gauche c'est
globalement la gauche on a dit les verts
à un moment
où sont les verts je les dis et je suis
très tranquille puisque j'ai écrit un
livre dans lequel je disais à peu près
ce qui va se passer donc moi je ne dis
rien d'autre que ce que je disais il ya
six mois j'ai pour être entendu j'ai
même été ignorés j'ai demandé un débat
parce que j'avais parfaitement compris
que cette impréparation
cette incapacité à prendre en compte à
la fois la dimension globale du projet
qu'on doit porter pour la france et la
question des couches insécurisés allait
coûter très cher
c'était le 100e débat je vais pas faire
en tout cas moi j'étais candidat un vrai
débat et je pense qu'il était utile de
le ps paie cette stratégie qui a été
celle de l'effacement
plutôt que de l'affirmation quand on ne
veut pas s'affirmer en considérant que
l'échec du quinquennat hollande était
telle qu'il fallait d'abord s'effacer on
finit par l'effacement les gens si vous
dites que il vaut mieux se mettre
derrière d'autre que de s'affirmer
soi-même un électeur niveau bas s'il
faut aller voter pour les autres j'irai
voter pour les autres vous pointez du
doigt en problème de leadership vous
pointez aussi du doigt un problème de
d'idées vous avez dénoncé récemment de
deux fractures majeur au sein de la
gauche la décroissance qui ne correspond
pas justement aux envies des classes
coup cité et que vous nommez un
sécuriser le hoki sme est-ce que face à
ces fractures vous pensez qu'il est
possible de réunir la gauche derrière on
peut réunir la gauche que s'il ya un
débat qui se qualifie de
seconde si vous n'étiez des fractures
la fracture entre frondeur et manuel
valls quand on gouverne une fracture qui
a rendu impossible toute synthèse la
fronde ayant emporté la primaire en plus
avec benoît hamon aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que je constate que derrière christiane
taubira par exemple c'est christian paul
qui était un des leaders de la fronde
donc la fronde continue à penser qu'elle
a raison sur le fond
si vous ne tranchait pas la question de
savoir si c'est elle qui a raison ou si
c'est unis
plus globalisante qui intègre à la fois
les couches insécurisés la question du
travail la question climatique mais pas
avec la conception de l'écologie qui est
comportementaliste qui a été sur la
ligne de la décroissance
personne n'a dit je lui ai dit dès le
départ ce travail aurait dû être fait
pourquoi nous sommes socialistes est pas
écologiste parce qu'il y avait 2-3
différence foot ils les expriment et les
affirmé et après les électeurs auraient
tranché durant les élections locales
aucun débat si ce n'est il faut qu'on se
rassemble vous répéter depuis quatre ans
si ce n'est qu'il faut qu'on se
rassemble l'union fera qu'on gagnera si
ce n'est qu'il faut qu'on sera sans eau
pendant ce temps là les électeurs qui ce
qu'ils écoutent qui se disent qu'est ce
qu'ils ont à dire l'union c'est pas un
programme c'est une tactique elle est
encore possible cette union pourvoi
jambes et ses fines on va pas
recommencer paquet elle est encore
possible qu'après vous allez me dire
alors jean-luc mélenchon ben ali a dit
que lui et yannick jadot ex caledon
arrêtons si j'ai un conseil à donner à
anne hidalgo c'est d'arrêter avec cette
fuite continue elle vers l'hypothèse de
l'union et du rassemblement pour la
victoire et d'affirmer maintenant
d'affirmer des positions un projet et un
programme et quand j'ai un projet un
programme un programme s'est
passablement la somme d'une dizaine ou
une quinzaine de mesures c'est un projet
pour la france doit présenter demain
pour vous programme alors demain jour de
grève je conseillerais de reporter sa à
vendredi peut-être que là on va me dire
bah oui mais samedi christiane taubira
annoncera à sa candidature vous voyez
bien qu'on est dans une totale
improvisation ce que je disais tout à
l'heure la gauche est totalement a perdu
tout sens même du du débat public de la
capacité qu'elle a parlé aux français
puisque anne hidalgo elle doit aller
jusqu'au bout dit il faut qu'elle
affirme ça sa candidature socialiste et
que le 10 avril dix ans bulletin anne
hidalgo candidate du ps je vous rappelle
que j'ai proposé un débat au ps ça on
s'en souvient il avait supprimé la
primaire j'ai proposé un débat j'ai dit
le minimum c'est qu'il y ait un vote il
ya eu un vote il y avait un vote pour
dire plus besoin de primaires c'est
terminé j'ai eu un vote pour dire on
veut à l'hidalgo contre stéphane le foll
le vote a eu lieu et maintenant on
dirait il ya qu'à refaire une primaire
qu'on a refusé avant qu'on a
rayé des statuts du parti socialiste et
on repart son primaire 12e point je vous
rappelle cette primaire dont on parle la
première pouvoir nier d'albums doit
participer ce que c'est que cette
primaire de quoi on parle qui organise
cette primaire je voulais dit tout à
l'heure quels sont les organisateurs on
nous dit c'est une plaire à votre
préférentiels bon il est il des débats
quelles sont ses 140 150 mais gens qui
sont assis personne n'a discuté de rien
ce sont des gens qui en plus sur des
positions politiques vous parliez du moc
isme des valeurs universelles l'un des
porte parole a clairement indiqué qu'il
fallait tourner le dos aux valeurs
universelles pour aller vers les
universel des universités voilà de quoi
on doit aller
c'est que ça ne correspond pas à ce que
je pense être juste pour les français et
la france
populaire mais je ne parle pas au nom
questionne de burin je veux dire
christiane taubira semble-t-il va
annoncer sa candidature donc le 15
janvier c'est ça le 15 janvier sans
avoir préparé me semble-t-il un débat et
présenter des grands projets des grandes
mesures
c'est christiane taubira avec ce qu'elle
représente elle a fait un facteur de
division pc lutter pour la petite une
offre politique de plus toujours dans le
même contexte c'est au nom du
rassemblement
des cartons la question des des prêts de
leurs emails les cartons la question de
la primaire arnaud montebourg va
vraisemblablement se rallier au hors
contexte primaire à christiane taubira
est ce qu'il faudrait pas que tous les
candidats ce rallye ce qui est demandé
par un certain deux militants derrière
le mieux placé dans les sondages
on commence à me lasser mais non mais
vous répéter ça ira jusqu'au bout c'est
qu'il suffirait se plaît à se ranger
derrière le mieux placé qui est de le
placer aujourd'hui jean-luc mélenchon
jean luc mélenchon penser que moi je
serai sur la ligne politique de jean luc
mélenchon qui a été très clair il dit
moi génie vous rassembler derrière moi
parce que moi j'ai une ligne écoutez non
si je regarde ce qui se passe avec
l'ukraine aujourd'hui d'ailleurs où
l'europe est absente alors qu'il ya des
bars entre poutine et les etats-unis
soulignent avec le format normandie qui
a intégré la france et l'allemagne avec
les états unis et l'urss qu'est ce que
dit jean luc mélenchon qu'est ce qu'il
dit sur le kazakhstan aujourd'hui ses
fans le feu ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
à deux gauches irréconciliables ces
pages mais pourquoi yens il ya deux
gauches qui aujourd'hui moi je ne me
réconcilie pas avec le choix politique
de jean luc mélenchon mais je vais pas
m'arrêter à lire et conciliables la
vraie question c'est qu'est ce qu'on est
capable de présenter et de portée pour
justement recréer un parti et une gauche
capable de gouverner la france c'est ça
la question à se recréer avec olivier
faure a je crois qu'aujourd'hui la
direction de ce parti qui a eu tous les
choix tactiques qui a fait cette
stratégie de l'effacement doit assumer
sa responsabilité dans le cas d'un
résultat aux présidentielles
législatives et ils devront assumer
pleinement et totalement les choix et
les erreurs qui ont été faites et c'est
clairement le critère mais il ya un
congrès après c'est quoi critères
écoutez je fais
qu'est ce que vous croyez qu aujourd'hui
on discute de quoi de quoi on parle là
vous parlez des sondages vous avez vu à
quel niveau et la gauche dans sa
totalité je fais part parlé du
match
regardez son second tour si je vous dis
ce matin je suis sûr qu anne hidalgo
sera au second tour mais vous ne souriez
déjà ton côté moi je ne fais rien
l'envol je les forme à quitter le ps
après les jeux ne faire bientôt tout ça
que de dire ce que j'avais écrit ya six
mois voilà et je constate que ce que
j'ai écrit et enfin de se vérifier parce
qu'on n'a pas été capable
de faire un choix qui n'est pas
simplement un choix tactique mais qui
était un choix politique on a compris
vous nous dites endwar est va s'affirmer
s'affirmer à doit aller jusqu'au bout
est ce que vous qui connaissez bien le
parti socialiste il peut survivre un
score inférieur à 5 % qui entraînera
revanche je pense que le parti
socialiste est qu'il est là aujourd'hui
avec cette ligne là est un parti qui n'a
plus de capacité à pouvoir porter un
message politique la preuve
oui j'ai fait pas effondré il ya le
parti socialiste aujourd'hui quand la
candidate
soutenue par le parti sioniste encore je
sais pas jusqu'à quand puisqu'il ya des
moeurs non mais c'est pas moi qui ait un
doute je suis dit c'est pas moi
il ya eu des débats au bureau national
hier soir il semblerait que tout le
monde soit soit ligne de la primaire
populaire maintenant
tout ça
est relâché par le ps mais je n'en sais
rien faudra poser la question mais je
vois qu'il ya des débats qui commença
comme a tourné ce que j'avais dit
d'ailleurs à l'époque bon bref donc tout
ça moi je dis maintenant aide à une
dalle go il ya une seule chose à faire
au moins porter un projet pour la france
et arrêter ces espèces de tactique qui
ont été depuis début un jeu qui
n'intéressent pas au fond les français
tout le monde et pour l'union mais à
voir le spectacle qui est donné
aujourd'hui de la gauche franchement je
comprend du français se détournent elles
bougent la question qui tu as à perdre
la présidentielle ne serait pas de
sauver au moins les législatives oui
mais là l'inversion du calendrier qui a
été fait sous jospin avec deux
quinquennats je vous le rappelle il ya
quelque chose qui est assez mécanique
entre la présidentielle et justin
que vaut penser que vous sauverez
législatives en ne se préoccupant pas de
la présidentielle nous paraît là pour le
coup un choix stratégique et tactique
très compliqué et très hasardeuse pour
reprendre une belle formule de lionel
jospin sur une dissolution fut un toit
merci beaucoup merci stéphane le foll
d'avoir été nommé ce matin
[Musique]